hey leute weg kommt zu diesem scream ich
habe gerade das gestartet und ihr wisst
ja bereits 2007 ist da unten stehen
kleine kreative modus nicht weiter dass
man ein bisschen paar leute da sind
regen stopp ich habe gerade noch mal von
regel untergestellt und jetzt kommt auch
direkt losgehen
wir warten noch ganz kurz bis alle da
sind halt leute hallo fabio hallo für
ein hallo melvin hall o dr team hallo
passy youtube hallo benny alessio hallo
erde hallo adriano henry hallo jannes ja
ne ist der beste job der welt mit am
start
ich bin zu leise da kann ich ein
bisschen was ändern aber fehler oder
geht es nicht leute die man halt ja
genau das waren alle leute die ihr da
jetzt gerade neu sind und wir sehen hier
jetzt schon diesen kreativ modus ich
habe den fall nur ganz kurz gesehen aber
so holy shit man kann so eine eigene
insel erschaffen geisteskrank ja genau
auf jeden fall wenn ich jetzt mal
auschecken was da so abgeht das lied
einem server gar die ganze zeit online
echte erst mal was so im item shop ist
bereit den neuen modus abchecken
es ist jetzt nichts neues dass gott
alles schon schon gern ist zwar cool
wenn man sich die ranken
schon hier kann man sich diese algen
zurück
knochen los nein natürlich ist opa bin
habe ich schon in männlich aber halt
auch nur er darf ich mitspielen ja ich
würde es gleich danach auch mal
mitspielen wenn der bock habt und
genauso wähle dein stil hast du da kann
man als ziel wählen aber so bickel neue
scans gibt es nicht oder also soweit ich
das jetzt teil eines okay ja gut dann
ist das so weil ja ganz interessant
ok kreativ modus spielen ist es bei 8 es
bei war dass gerade bei servern oder
janis meinte für kreativ wo das musst du
den bettel pass in battle royale haben
auch die kriege ich denn er muss sich
den erfolg kaufen oder ich geh jetzt mal
zurück zur spielmodus auswahl jan jetzt
sehen wir mal was ich tun muss für den
kreativ modus gegen den job ich war
gerade in den job von item shop und da
gibt es halt einfach nichts neues ich
habe jetzt gerade den schon gekauft also
blieb ganz ruhig ganz ruhig ok egal also
der hintergrund gefährt auf jeden fall
ziemlich geil das ist also
schneelandschaft was natürlich voll
passend ist zu winter als absolut geil
team lego fan ich gerade habe ich den
play button nein ich bin ja also gut
eigentlich müsste ich schon habe mich ja
schon 100.000 aber sei aber noch kein
bleiben so geschickt zu sagen schlimm
geht es im battle paares battle vs
[Musik]
und das war es wert das paket ja ok den
hätten wir auf jeden fall dass stoffe an
sechs gegenstände werden freigeschaltet
okay ja ja ja ja ja bücher das also
genau okay gibt es irgendwas
interessantes das ist eine lackierung
gehen wir mal was gibt's da denn so
alles habe selbst noch nicht gemacht
aber müsste es doch etwas kaufen da
müsstest du kreativspiel erstellen
können okay kann ich mir den
quali-spielen mit zuschauern spielen
dann ist geht das
ich sehe gerade staatsgelder gute auch
gerade live ist wo ihr ganz am ende
gibt's adhs kann holyfield aber das
glaube ich das glaube ich tun wir uns
nicht an ich glaube hier kann man die
cutscene wir holen habe ich die zahlen
noch nicht angepasst
[Musik]
sky gemacht
ich mache ja mal ganz kurz in hohem
grade
[Musik]
aber übel geil also ja dass man sie gar
nicht lange auf unseren zuschauern
spielte nicht gut dann später mal ein
paar leute von euch initiativ muss das
wirklich alle haben ja da mehr 60 leute
angepasst oder das sehr heftig
erst mal alle zuschauer wir spielen
jetzt kreativ modus ihren er gerade eben
den bettel paris geholt und dann will
ich mit ein paar leuten von euch spielen
wenn es denn so leicht geht das
vorstelle dass meine gratis musste gehen
und siplace schreibt gerade die cutscene
schon zum fünften mal gerade so dann
gehen jetzt mal zurück in kreativ modus
erst mal hallo noch andere leute die
gerade aktiv sind und dann habe ich auch
nur noch 950
so gehen den shop bitte klima weiter von
der alten job also geht's an den
schlachten haben wir ja sehr alt ventura
sie auch als der rebell der ist ja auch
alt und alles ist ja hier also was ich
halt die cool fanden war jonglieren habe
ich mir das ding auch gegönnt
ja ganz genau deswegen würde ich jetzt
mal zurück in den spielen mainz auswahl
gehen und dann direkt meinen kreativen
modulreihen starken gehe in den shop
neben karriere
aha gut ja aber da gibt es auch nichts
neues oder beste gegend ja so zeigt
battle pass gut zeigt bei dettelbach mal
hier ich habe jetzt den wald muss
gekauft und was es gibt ja hier gibt es
auf jeden fall schneeflocken dass
kondensstreifen das schon ziemlich litt
und dann gibt es auch geil
der ist geil da ist cool jetzt richtig
dann musik gibt jetzt neue musik also im
auto das verstehe ich nicht
genau das gibt dann gibt es hier noch
ein
santas gilt als auch ziemlich geil war
der sind geil also der ist heftig der
rucksack sie haben es ja gerade eben ein
eis puck aber es ist was ist ein
spielzeug ist ja genau der gleiter ist
wenn ich jetzt nicht so krass dann der
dsv hat er alles richtig mit der jetzt
richtig lied du bist der erste der jetzt
kräftig spiel endlich habe ich endlich
hat nicht genug geld für den pass ja
dafür konnten wir den jetzt hab ich mir
dann schon gekauft war das auch geil
symbole
das passt auch gut markiert dann hier
der gleiche name ist geil hier schenken
das ist ein geiler rucksack lebt
bisschen sieht ein bisschen dumm aus
aber ich bin gleich das ist ein heftiger
gleiter holy shit
das galt es gibt es auch ganz schick da
wir sind hier ist noch eine musik aber
kann ich anhand keine ahnung
und da ist halt der krasseste scanner
als könig der als heftig okay dann
spielen wir eigentlich fertig modus
öffne einen server freunde von freund
starten
ok und jetzt also jetzt kann einfach
also wie läuft es kann ja wohl freunde
jetzt rein oder was also keine ahnung
keine ahnung aber die wir abdecken was
da abgeht
[Musik]
geil das ziel festlegen insel zweimal
das verstehe ich jetzt absolut nicht
hier ist eine border also vier stunden
kann man hier muss ich jetzt das hat er
funktioniert so geil ist kein
heruntersetzen handy ist das denn
freunde müssen darauf spiel klicken
jannis bist du befreundet oder besuche
freunde oder wie finde ich die leute
hinzu ok alles klar dann checken wir mal
ich mache ganz kurz meine fans kam nach
links unten damit ihr die website die
auch gar nicht
naja ich mal eine sekunde macht die
facebook mal hier rüber gehen sie im
hauptmenü auf muss natürlich hat mir in
die und jetzt alle man kann was man kann
fliegen was heftige ja gut also man kann
jetzt schon mal fliegen classics
entfernen was ist das okay kann ich
jetzt hier einfach bauen ja da kann ich
wieder pflege modus
und ich kann bestimmt auch mal wirklich
wechseln
da kann ich jetzt einfach bauen das cool
das ist ja geil da könnte man
theoretisch könnte man auch gegen eine
kämpfen oder so da kann man da nur könnt
ihr noch gehen kann kennt kann jetzt
oder wohl auch nicht weil ich sie jetzt
keine waffen zumindest was gibt's da
drin auch nichts
ich glaube ja durch die skype und links
ganz oben
januar zuerst ganz partie aus sonst
stehen wir als ok so vor allem zu finden
wer altenburg schreibt martin buck hier
ist schon standard skill auf jeden fall
am stadtrand von blog schreibt euren
fordert nahm hier einen chat dann würde
ich jetzt einfach mal eben ja vielen
dank an die 130 zuschauer was los was
ist los
ok also so referentin ehrlich dir immer
hinzufügen so jährigen unterstrich
extreme 808 den finger hinzu dann 22 12
und dann lag itv lage tv der blue master
hab ich dich nicht schon irgendwie wie
heißt du wenn ja also gut und die können
jetzt einfach mal reinschauen oder was
wie ist das heute das war er hier sind
läuft es auch geil aber gibt's hier
waffen irgendwie hast du in der richtung
kreativzentrum okay
cool
geil geil geil ja kann erst um 2 ab der
ihn muss noch gemacht werden okay dass
irgendeiner von euch schon im game dann
würde ich jetzt erstmal noch normale
runde spielen kann ich hier noch nicht
fliegen
ja da kann man hier irgendwie was mir
wirklich noch bauen
na ja ich würde sagen ich geh jetzt mal
aber zuerst einmal raus jetzt mal raus
wo hier raus gelassen ja und dann will
ich mal schauen was die anderen modi
können ob es etwas neues gibt oder sonst
irgendwelche in freiheit gibt hey you ja
genau so gut als ganzes gibt es denn da
müssen die leute rein
okay okay lewis schon beim start hörst
du mich
hallo hey hast du eine ahnung wie das
funktioniert hier perfekt verteidigt
jetzt aber noch mal zurück in den
normalen modus ich wird dann vielleicht
später noch mal kreativ spielen ich
gerne zurück gruppe verlassen des
spielens auswählen und spielmann
normalmodus einen nicht kreativen
irgendwas imperial mal gucken ob da
irgendetwas gibt was gibt es da ja zur
entdeckertour ok skript immer noch
gruppen teile also damals noch nichts
gemacht und es gibt den kritik modus
hier gibt's auch ein kreativ modus okay
aber das sind ja die haben wieder neue
blöcke so den gibt's ja gar nicht die
haben wir neue baum oder sehr heftig das
sagt das schon da wollte kreativ morgens
okay aber dazu muss ich dann ja auch gar
nicht jetzt
dazu muss ich ja gar nicht da extra hier
eingehen na ja ich würde überhaupt nicht
spielte erst mal eine runde gruppen wenn
irgendwann also ich mach jetzt noch mal
kreativ modus so leute geht es ist keine
eigentliche funktionalität modus und
dann müsstet ihr bereit öffne einen
server starten also
ich mach gleich mal in florida zu leise
war so erstmal investieren muss kommt
laut und hier alles andere weise
annehmen jungs man hat jetzt gar nicht
schwarz
ja gut dann würde ich jetzt einfach mal
also plasma jetzt einmal zu bahrain
so gibt es ja echt keine waffen so dass
erfolge zu werden dafür finden würde
aber kann man echt nur bei uns ich kann
ja auch nicht kreativ sein urlaub stehen
junge mann hell also ob das auch so im
leben hatte ich kann nichts bekommt man
hier ja wo ist ja da hinkommt passau
hätte hat sich einfach
junge gut ich glaube dir mal zum
kreativzentrum zurück an die leute die
jetzt mit mir da drin sind geht man am
besten
[Musik]
ja an die leute die jetzt wieder in der
welt präsent geben am besten kann man am
besten zu mir rein
so schaffe dein eigenes fordern alles
was du hier gespeichert ok also gehe ich
jetzt da ich gerne noch alt drücken
wahrscheinlich oder awo was bist du über
mehr drin
die website komplett anders aus was
heftig sehe ich gerade erst guck mal was
es sein warum gibt es auf jeden fall die
ganzen härte das heft ich hab ich das
jetzt erst sie war oder morgen bigben
hin klar warum nicht
erst am big ben ja man heftig kann die
sachen einfach ein cheat seiten hier
als ob das ist auch die uhren gegen gras
ich hab so ein handy und da kann ich die
sache selber so kopieren und du hast ich
glaube ich habe mir die hier erstmals
auch weil ich gebe euch mal kann ich
irgendwie waffen wie flugzeug
ach du bist mein team ich kann nur den
dahin gehen
horst und wenn ich fliegen können marc
risse response also wenn nicht dann ist
das bitter dass die gesellschaft genau
du kannst alles einstellen über das
handy glaube ich okay handy punkt
verbrauchs gegenstände hat kann hier auf
jeden fall mal ein paar impulsen heraus
ballern dann paar heftige einbußen herz
dann wenn ihr ein bisschen
baumaterialien wollt könnt ihr nicht
bange ich dir recht irgendwie einstellen
ich habe ja auch noch ein paar ja
absolut ganz krank
ich glaube sobald man hat der modus
funktioniert es ja auch ziemlich geil
also können wir jetzt noch mal ich guck
mal noch was gibt es denn hier noch so
neu also es gibt auf jeden fall gut dann
guck mal fertig objekte es gibt sie noch
so geil ist im ziel 2 gibt es die ganze
gebäude aus vor dem halt so richtig das
ist ja mal nach oben
[Musik]
also das war geil das ist auch ganz geil
das team jetzt mal aus die aus westen
und dann ja gut
da wurde ich ja noch mal dass hier das
muss ich auch ausrüsten heftig ja da hat
er mich eiskalt gekillt flugzeuge was
flugzeug wo ist das flugzeug machen man
letzter ist und man es mit einzusetzen
ja ok
größer schreibt face kennt übrigens auf
die anderen ja auch vielen dank übrigens
wenn ihr es nicht gemacht hat mal bei
mir bei switch reihen könnte hier
abdecken oder er gönnt euch den ersten
link in der beschreibung oder was machst
du jetzt also ihr können auch gerne er
den ersten linken beschreibung mal
gönnen da oder den link in der
schreibung einfach da habe ich nehme ich
meinen tisch link reingemacht der
tritsch link ist auch auf twitter ist
auch genau hier
hier ist ja da kann er ja mal
reinschauen ich habe immer noch genau
330 zuschauer sich entweder ist die zahl
eingefroren oder da ich glaube jetzt
eingefroren
sorry an denen auf jeden fall vom
fliegen und mit meiner
[Musik]
so richtig bunt für alle
so jäger hat einfach spaß gemacht sich
herz auf
weil es aber auch von der witzigen modus
dagegen so leute die alle waffen haben
und nicht verschließen können hier in
der luft und nicht nur den
dafür hat das faktor jetzt ab oder ich
gebe immer noch ein paar raketenwerfer
sind ja hier aus dem hause wissen
ausrüsten
wir wollen natürlich noch ein bisschen
kondition dafür gab der dieb ist also
geboten haben oder
ja geil
raki flugzeug alle leute flugzeug sind
bei gerät geräte ua war war es okay also
dass auch eine plattform
okay was ich brauche jetzt macht ein
flugzeug dann kann ich alle im flugzeug
schild könnte eigentlich bauen
nein kann ich das irgendwie ein schild
weist dass jemand das kommt mir vor wie
der minecraft kreativ modus antwort gut
ich glaube ich ziemlich tun
ein kleiner flughafen finden sie weitere
weg aus absolut genial
es würde ja ich weiß ich bin so
flughafen ein flugzeug gezeigt
also ich möchte mal flugzeug wenn ihr
wollt hallo flugzeug bringt so genervt
gerne gönnen ich nicht einmal 1 fliegen
auf leertaste geht man scheinbar gas ich
weiß es nicht der fall der junge war
sollte nach oben lenken junge perfekt
wird der anderen modi anderen modi gibt
dieser flugzeuge schauen wir mal
entscheid gibt die flugzeuge auf den
normalen modus also echt das ist geil
sind die guten
hier legen auf ein paar kaputte
flugzeuge absolut geil empfindlich
machen ein paar neue halter 500
zuschauer ich sehe gerade jetzt ich hab
gerade erst eine aktualisierte ja selbst
noch liegen soll
hier noch ein flugzeug das lesen ein
bisschen den boden habe ich mir das mal
als ob er gleich so über die schrauben
macht heftig wie fliegen kann ich ja
auch irgendwie
ja ich hatte ja so gut einfach in den
zug zurück was wenn wir kommen nach oben
ich muss ja mal die maus was möchte ich
mal die maus ist einfach nicht mehr
genug
ja aber ich kann aber auch erst drücken
um mein gott bin ich tun
oh mein gott bin ich da
nein wtf are als ob es ist etwas
so kam einmal konstanz wie auch immer
das geht heavy macht diese jungen leute
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich schon wenn ich es wüsste
wie acht kannte ganz schließen das muss
ich ja noch nicht
ich bin ausgestiegen gemeinden ja so
dass glückliches mit
gut da eigentlich selber umgebracht
kann ich noch ich habe noch ein paar
freunde ein
ja so freund hinzufügen leute wenn ihr
wolltet mich mal dann füge ich euch
jetzt hinzu oder schreibt neue namen mit
2 sk meine insel aller schlimmste spiel
war es ziemlich team street vor
kooperativ zeitlimit fünf minuten muss
man vielleicht im teamsprint
ja das ist auf jeden fall spiel
einstellungen unendlich munition aus war
da ist die ganze setting selbst noch mal
ganz kurz für euch hier twitter.com
story und dann ein t der link ist auch
einfach mal in der geschichte wie die
beschreibung können ja gerne mal
reinschauen da wie jetzt dann demnächst
regelmäßige streams geben natürlich auch
heute noch youtube aber wenn ihr mehr
sehen wollt dafür brauchst jetzt mal den
link hier bisher ein makel gerne drauf
drücken und ihr auftritt schreien aber
mir wird schreiben folgen das wäre
wunderbar
dann gehe ich noch mal hier rein auf
meine insel keine nämlich sachen
einstellen die insel werkzeug insel
zurücksetzen ein spiel bearbeitung von
allen so jetzt kann er bauen leute
thomas thumann ja eine gute idee mit dem
kann niemals screen eigentlich sogar
cool
[Musik]
ok werde ich als ok jetzt eskaliert es
so hart wenn du jetzt hier handy hat
okay hashtag 1312 dich habe ich mal geht
es
ich war auch den rap den laptop 0 0
geendet
danach besteht switch dot com
tom ridge tv ist es ja mal danke für den
do der mir gerade geschrieben dass ich
das ändern muss da ist natürlich recht
dum dum dum dum jetzt richtig
strichpunkt ev sorry
also da ich erhalte dadurch hat sich da
es tut mir leid dass er dumm so genau
er kann sie mit schreiben ich heiße
scheele die 04
ja klar für die 0 4 0 4
dann haben wir damals noch zählen
robbie zeitpunkt 2 dann haben wir einmal
noch die h h oder den tag 9 29
und dann haben wir den tv
das neg hatte ja könnte ja jetzt alle
rein schauen einfach oder wissen dass
ich glaube ich können wir da mal was ist
das denn
kaymer cool punkt anzeige crazy was das
schadens balken h
das ja einmal draußen gerade ein grund
aber als du bist ein bismarck hallo du
bist
okay wir sind es aus leute könnt ihr mir
jetzt einfach rein tollen oder was wir
sehen was aus mit den ganz neuen können
die da in meinen service rein was ist so
weil ich jemand was den namen falsch
geschrieben tg reserve
du hast immer wieder jetzt einfach
reinschauen können weil ich habe absolut
keine ahnung ob wir reinkommen können
währenddessen läuft was ist das denn her
sollte ich hier nicht schneller werden
wo aber diese sind so langsam
ok
hier noch einer der umbau kann was kommt
diese methode ist was ich mache
icon auflegen er hat aber sie jetzt das
objekt lenovo ist hervest junge jammer
denn so einer keine boni mehr
das ist ein bisschen belasten ich muss
mir mal uniform jede waffe ganz viel
sport
bitte nicht wo der markt los wo er
übertreibt halt ja den habe ich mir
gegönnt
wo er jetzt ist geil ihr könnt jetzt
einfach der mir ein schwabe
nein der und auch jetzt können sie ein
flugzeug soll ich ihnen sie das
vermessen oder soll ich ihnen lassen
ja ja ja ist doch früher aufstehen
aber ich leute schreibt mir mal einer
ich habe kein aber verpasst weil sie ja
schon geschrieben hat einfach einmal
einen chat ob er mitspielen können
sobald er mein freund hat oder ob das
nur in den server anschauen könnt wenn
ihr ja bei ins normale für unendlich
munition angereist recht meine insel
viele entscheidungen ressourcen an und
in die position auch an
so kann ziemlich eltern heiße become a
row 44
das mahnmal become a row 44 werde leider
nur schreibt nur einnahmen nur rein wenn
ihr jetzt dann direkt mit spielen wollt
dann würde ich auch eingehen brothers xd
den hätte ich auch noch 26 d
ok dann die hg auch noch gerettet dank
an die box
wer will noch 60 ps 60 70 usd nach
dann so wollen wir es jetzt mal ich
stelle einfach mal die maus war auch so
ein dass wir immer nur zu zweit sind
glaube ich damit jeder gegen jeden spiel
muss oder so oder sie jetzt ja ganz
ruhig
ich glaube aber herzlich jetzt nicht
sicher
trotzdem fliegen ist ja richtig geil der
modus erhält die jetzige sieht das
herzig spielen das ist ziemlich gut dann
wurde es geht jetzt gleich fünf minuten
lang und danach geht normal weiter
er habe ich hatte mir das herz gerät
komplett ich hab's euch gesagt
dann für das konzert an der stelle
da oben jetzt schauen wir kleiner warum
da so hey okay ist viel angenehmer wenn
ich diesen modus auf herrschen würde
oder halt dieses flugzeug auch herrschen
würde nein nicht viel
ist ja irgendwie ja ja kurz den
hartplatz und chatten junge okay
natürlich
zur installation einfach
kannst du mich erden heißt dr ludwig at
gerne auch mal ein paar aber er glaubt
dass service pflegefall oder album
gibt's ja noch bei der eine war vier
jahre gibt es ein typisches skalica
munition wir ein bisschen tricksen oder
ganzen freaks awn snack ich mir denn wo
ist er denn jetzt kann einige lange
geraden augen verloren denn ihr seid ja
ok
keiner bauen das bin ich ja gut
er wurde dafür dass man tot ist selber
also er ist echt total geil ich glaube
man muss ich noch ein bisschen was er
damit ausländern das seltsame an alle
hier meint rich name da können wir gerne
mal rein folgen da kommen jetzt sogar
und regelmäßige streams der link wald ev
hat das einzutreten was ich natürlich
absolut verstehen kann
der link der ist auch noch mal in der
video beschreibung genau so ja da kommt
man geboren und dann ist direkt hier so
ein ding sie aber zu jung jetzt
die baufelder gut dass ich drei leben
habe so sehen wir absolut natürlich ganz
auch ziemlich
wir sind jetzt alle kämpfen wie so ein
hund wäre kein leben war
sie haben gewonnen also nein sager
kleine ich noch mal gepennt als büro hg
der markt hat offenbar abgeräumt hier
der markt hat auf jeden fall gewarnt im
team sechs natürlich einnahm startete
geil
ja so jetzt ist es kann ich wieder ich
finde jetzt gerade einfach durch gegeben
habe als ob alles gut geht
ich kann es gar nichts machen kann ich
meine es captain fielen auf den boden
soll das so sei ich weiß es
ja nicht gehen jetzt wieder
ja jetzt ist
h
ist ja
das zu können
nein
ja soll ich sie nicht retten kann was
ist das denn
da sind wir
klar das hat natürlich auch immer aus
alter hat das beckie laser jetzt holy
shit
das war's also ins flugzeug heftig wenn
man das noch ein bisschen joshua klar
kenntlich macht also flugzeug setzen wir
uns ein bisschen steuern kann man sich
natürlich definitiv nicht
wir haben ganz angeschlossen
so also ging das flugzeug aber nicht
hier keine chance wenn da jemand dran
ist jetzt geherrscht was ich jetzt nicht
da aber wenn ich schon so easy da leute
wegklatschen kann ja dann kann es auch
jeder absolut geil da waren wir noch
leute aber ich mag das flugzeug das
kennt auch echt nichts nein flieg flieg
[Musik]
nochmal rein ist da jemand
da ist ein
ja gut da kam auch schon die rakete
ich hab ich meine wasserverträge ist
einfach das ist jetzt auch egal
ja erst mal vielen dank für knapp 500
zuschauer geils über heftig diesen
kreativ modus kann man nur spielen wenn
man die beide per sofort oder
ja und danke nochmal für das link in den
pausen link mal gucken was abgeht das
ist okay so
dann sehen wir was brauchen was ist ein
bodyscanner die gar nicht mehr rein dies
geil dann es gab vielleicht ganz gut
aber ich glaube nicht dass firmen da
könnte ich mir richtig dagegen richtig
dass keine gefahr mehr dass ein handy
haben wir ja die braune technisch das
richtig so wo ist da nichts hallo gut da
hat er für uns auch ein gs ende genommen
leider denkst du dass luft bleibt ich
glaube nicht so lange wobei das flugzeug
ist glaube ich so viel arbeit gewesen
ich glaube die nehmen sich einfach aus
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass dieses
flugzeug rausnehmen das war so viel
arbeit
ja ich glaube ich mache ja auch manchmal
ein bisschen spannender weil die da
unten alle wiesen superhelden muss ja
junge mann ludo hund
und spaß spaß natürlich spaß natürlich
fröhlichen nicolas ja das stimmt nicht
der nikolaus manchmal ganz gut
meine face canyon ticken
jetzt hab ich das gameplay verrutscht
ich meines klein bisschen größer
so zeigt jetzt muss ich mir noch mal den
nehme ich hier dann nämlich den davis
cup und dann hole ich mir vielleicht
noch
fertige objekt uns irgendwas hohes
irgendwie so den den der weg hat jemand
im hintergrund ist ein förder irgendwie
so ausrasten einmal das war ich auch ein
bisschen rein einfach gut das ist hause
perfekt perfekt
ob jetzt aber mal ein paar von diesen
gebäuden hierauf ja du kriegst du
kriegst gebäude im gebäude fest ich ja
wahrscheinlich recht in der luft mit dem
ding ja so geht es nicht so du kriegst
gebäude hier noch eins drauf er hat
sogar gebäude aufs andere gebäude werfen
glaube ich geht ist natürlich glaube ich
mache jetzt mal alles hier voll mit
gebäude aller hier noch ein gebäude
drauf hat kann ich gar nicht mehr schade
aber hier noch war ja junge der der hat
mphase kleiner ja okay vielleicht ein
kleiner wieder mache ich gleich
sie hat mir auch einfach klar sein
müssen dass danke danke hätte klar sein
müssen dass keine mein gesicht sehen
will so groß so dass das los achja
umleiten dann gehe ich als man direkt
auf sprachen weil der ist ein bisschen
hektisch genau
solange erstmal hier so gut wie keiner
von denen sieht weil sonst die kühe mich
immer wenn ich jetzt mal hier hinten
eine schöne raumsonde dann kann ich mir
wie god mode machen oder so
meine insel spielt einstellungen fall
fahren ja da habe ich jetzt auch mal
geld dann stelle ich aber mal kurz die
ganzen power ist für die leute aus
ja aber richtig ein bisschen so ich
glaub ich bin ich ein bisschen safe
außer jemand guckten stream an
aber ich bin jetzt ein paarmal das ding
bereits wie bilden und ein paar lustige
und dann kann ich mir noch eine von den
un ja bisher munition vielleicht auch
dann durchaus mithalten so und dann
freut sich ansonsten noch die infrarot
ir geil und normal ist gar die kann ich
mir nicht nehmen
mein glaube den brauche ich aber gar
nicht so trinkt
ich wollte liegen nein ist voll nervig
dass man ihn fallen wenn man fällt nicht
die
nein sagen
ein hacker g
also habe ich den nichts dafür
ja man doch das war es thomas hauser
postfach ich hab kein pass vor
vielleicht kommt das noch irgendwann
aber momentan nicht
nein bleibe stehen junge katalane klar
dass bei mir der ok aber der der beute
mitgehen geil so vielen dank an die
knapp 600 zuschauer gerade wir sind
gerade in kreativ modus und entdecken
aber mal gerade was alles so abgeht
da unten sind auch schon leute das
problem ist ich kann mir also generell
zur klärung an die leute die jetzt und
ich kann man kann ja einfach alles
entschieden
dementsprechend sind ja auch antwort die
gebäude zur komplett crazy ich werde
jetzt auch noch ein paar von euch werden
aber gerade ist eigentlich gut voll der
server deswegen bin ich ein bisschen
warten da hinten sind ein paar leute die
jetzt scheinlich bock drauf haben mich
zu quälen ich bitte euch einfach ist zu
lassen ich glaube ist aber auch egal wie
man jetzt hier gerade sieht deswegen
also
so der hat einen grund genommen habe das
schild rang ich stelle jetzt mal ganz
kurz
ich stelle es mir jetzt selber ganz kurz
so eine insel
das war was ist das was sagen die noch
spiel teams - drei spiele ja aber
respawn hör mal ich würde jetzt gerade
einstellen
die jetzt behält man auf jeden fall die
ganzen items wenn man stirbt das wird
natürlich dann schauen wir mal was und
zwar das erwarten dass insel werkzeug
nur miranda tussi ich habe euch auch
erstmal eure handys weggenommen
ich glaube jetzt hallo ja gut das ist
hier aber auch nicht haben das gehört
ganz kurz mal
ich kann mich bewegen ich glaube jetzt
klärt das aber gerade deswegen ist es
ein bisschen standbild mäßig gerade aber
jetzt die zweite und ich glaube ich wäre
dankbar zuschauer mal bisschen ärgern
ja du kannst deine tage mal españa
anwenden dürfen wir gerade schon mal
wirklich leid irgendwie so hoffentlich
ja diese kleine unterbrechen wir nicht
weiter zu nutzen schauen wir selber für
meinen tisch zu machen oder wenn der
faulheit was auch das beständige jetzt
den link in der beschreibung anklicken
und mir damit es folgen falls er tritt
ab sofort überhaupt
und ja genau will ich der einzige jetzt
eigentlich hatte der ja nicht leben kann
oder geht es in anderen auch so weil
also ich kann ja jetzt hier nichts mehr
anwenden was geändert aber es hilft
nichts
ja das macht alles kaputt ja absolut ich
ganz gut zurück zum quellenpark hier
geht absolut gar nix hier geht absolut
gar nichts ich kann nichts machen ja
auch nicht machen ich weiß nicht ich
glaube gestattet aber jetzt geht
irgendwas ich jetzt glaube ich zurück in
dieses zentrum von diesem kreativ ding
dann geht's auf jeden fall ab
netzwerkfehler ja wahrscheinlich weil
gegen die ultra viele leute einfach
jetzt gerade worten spielen und dann
sind die server bisschen überlastet dann
fühlen wir mal noch so behaupten wir
gehen es noch mal einen kredit boris
rhein
und ja ich hätte jetzt mal verloren
schreibt mir jetzt mal euren namen
reinigt mal die den verleugnen können
andere von euch damit reagiere die nehme
ich an
ich kann auch nicht enden hättet mich
einfach am besten da nehme ich euch
jetzt gerade an
so gleitet er ist ein bisschen meiner
meinung nach aber wahr wenn man passt
mal auf im spind ich habe ein neues
emotion und guest geil geil sie mal dass
uns gegönnt
der ist auch doof
genau ich glaube ein paar freunde fragen
wurden jetzt erst raus geschickt weil
ich den vorschlag im spiel war oder so
deswegen nicht perfekt abbrechen so ich
glaube ich hat jetzt ein paar neue
freunde dazu gewonnen
[Musik]
so ich werde mal noch mal den xd xd
unseren elf so das projekt okay jetzt
hatte ich genug
ich kanns einfach annehmen und dahin
kreativ modus reinräumen so hat auch
einen und genau die haben alle augen
server
ja aber ich mache mir meine eigenen
staat so cool 600 zuschauer gerade
vielen dank leute ist mir eine ehre so
gehen wir mal hallo lekker mobil ihren
arbeitgebern reinach slap natürlich wäre
das letzte mal ganz kurz mal ein titel
im stream vorteil sie sind sieben
kreativ modus mit zuschauern anzocken
ja
perfekt
sogar bei 69 zuschauer jetzt richtig
wichtig da wir gehörten ihr bett das
schreiben von einer könnt ihr selber
bank war
zudem habe die natürliche trage
wunderschöne ist die wohl jetzt
gespeichert das bauen auch schon jetzt
eine leute ich will jetzt die welt noch
ein bisschen ausbauen ausrüsten
hier arbeiten da hinten und da damit sie
nicht so leer ist absolut geil weil
davor war es immer so dass man neben
hatte dass man sich an lebens bestecken
kann jetzt mit dass hier also wenn du
das dann soll das kompakte desktop und
da kommen jetzt das ja auch geil weil
kann man sich jetzt ein bisschen
verstecken und hat nicht immer das
problem dass ein leute ständig gehen ja
jetzt ein paar neue flugzeuge glaube ich
gut dass ich so viele flugzeuge gehen
wir dorthin gebaut hat und einfach
absolut jeder die flugzeuge nur kaputt
gemacht das ist natürlich ja natürlich
was gebaut ich glaube es reicht es aber
erst mal fürs erste und dann was brauche
ich dann was ich hätte gerne gar nicht
japan halouska kann ja weil ich ich
glaube im modus ist gerade ja so dass
spieler daran und munition an ist ja das
ist ziemlich
ganz gelassen dann hätte ich noch gerne
ich will jetzt gerne ein bisschen
snipern üben jetzt geht ja um nichts da
würde ich mir ein tier das ist dass die
repetitive magazin größe 1
hier gibt es ja irgendwo auch eine öfter
als ein mal schießen kann gibt es hier
schon mal gar nicht würde ja schade dass
natürlich absolut ja trotzdem nehme ich
dich trotzdem mal ein schuss nur an
ach die leute haben jetzt alle keine
waffen gehen also sollte ich mal ein
paar waffen herum körben oder denkt ihr
dass ich jetzt mal hier ein paar waffen
wurde heute stimmt wir haben paare
frankens werde ich lasse mir mal ein
paar waffen herum hageln können was ihr
wollt
so also ihr müsst nur gucken
ich habe mir über internet esborn ich
jetzt gerne mal ein paar waffen da könnt
ihr überall einfach dann waffen
raussuchen dann können wir uns wieder
mal keines betten geben
aber ja natürlich
die apk ein paar mal sollte pumpguns das
gas dann wohl sagen ja leute ja nichts
los
so
tanja bis rein fliegen ihr nicht super
hast so ein bisschen was zu dürfen
also wenn ihr wollt dann hat jetzt
hoffentlich alle eine weil ich habe
überall verteilt in der map ultra viele
waffen gehabt
ich mache ich mal was fahrzeuge hier 80
fahrzeuge müssten mit der 55
lotte wein natürlich
und jetzt das braucht noch mehr waffen
ich werde mich nicht töten ist supernett
pharma flugzeuge es gern mal flugzeug
ich weiß nicht welcher form noch nicht
gesehen aber ich weiß auch ein bisschen
flugzeug ist videos gleich auch noch mal
generell losgehen und wir werden es
generellen am besten schon jetzt so ein
paar mir einen server also alle die mich
zu freuen uns dass herr kohl wenn ihr
jetzt mal reinschauen würde ja das
wollte ich nur mal so gesagt haben und
hier liegen wirklich überall am boden
einige waffen herum
ich kann ja ich gerne mal alle immer
können
so habt ihr wisst noch die
baumaterialien
da der mist nur bleibt aber mal kurz
stehen bei ich weiß nicht ob es noch mal
erst gar keine 660 zuschauer gerade
jährlich kommt noch ein paar waffen aus
so jedenfalls üblichen der iskander von
dem ein paar okay ich glaube das war
jetzt auch nicht reichen langsam
ich hätte gerne redet nicht gehen ist
absolut nett und dann muss ich glaube
ich noch einstellen wollte ich jetzt
nicht sagen würde käme ich einfach nicht
ich hab's ich habe es in seinen augen
gesehen das mich gehen wollte absolut so
[Musik]
alles gab so ich geh jetzt mal kurz
meine insel und dann stelle ich mir die
unendliche zwischenahn und munition an
waffen bei limitierungen fallen lassen
sich aus jetzt bleibt jeder seine waffen
man muss nicht jeder neue sammeln wenn
er stirbt das ist nämlich nötig
die mal kurz ein buch so sei also der
krieg der del cati modus natürlich
überhaupt
ich möchte euch jetzt noch mal anhalten
hierbei tritt zu folgen wenn twitter und
genau regelmäßige stream
[Musik]
so kann man sich nicht mal da habe ich
die kraul schied hier gibt es nochmal so
[Musik]
weiß ich jetzt noch so ein modus meine
insel gibt es jetzt ein spiel das ich
dann machen wir es eben ihren eingeben
und zwei teams mit fünf minuten in ston
punkt sportlichen spiel
ich sah dass noch ein game zum mini
spiel und genau
gut die haben wir alle noch mal ist
glaube ich geht einfach wer die meisten
respekt so stelle ich mir das vor
oder habe ich gibt es gegner irgendwann
doch keiner haben ja keinen gemacht
jetzt geht für die bewährten team auch
gut da war gegner für chili kein gegner
dies weckt
vielen dank eine 700 zuschauer gerade
jetzt ein bisschen wenig gegner gefühlt
und sich sagen können jetzt mal wieder
die baumaterialien hier jeder das
baumaterialien hier drin sein
ja so kann es gehen
so kann's gehen gesehen hat das rating
kein gegner
der alte hass gegen ist ja kein aber
match ist auch gleich vorbei an der
stelle aber keine team wechseln ist
tätig wieviel gar nicht absolut keiner
gegen mich
aber damit ein bisschen zunächst ein
bisschen aus sicht von oben ist der
modus gratis der scheint momentan auf
dem bendplatz kaufen um den modus haben
zu können was ein bisschen weg ist aber
ja die meisten meinten dass der auch
irgendwann komplett kostenlos wird
präsident wir sind zwar 13
und genau dort schied als dreizehnter
setzen dann auch für alle geben auch
leute die die welt was nicht kaufen
können oder wollen oder genau
tschüss das war auf jeden fall selbst
mal kommando okay gilt der beiden 1976
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht ich
habe gerade den aktuellsten getauft und
damit läuft es so ist ja ein wake aber
dass man den bettel preiskrieg naja man
gucken
das war absolut unfair dass gerade
gelandet und schon wieder tut man es
denn da oben gemacht
also ich würde das eine bild flugzeug
aber okay ihr wollt dass ein flugzeug
fliegen kleinflugzeuge 11 wir müssen ein
paar jahre hier müssen warum liegen in
der europa league match gegen flugzeug
aus indem sie zuerst was scheinbar tut
nicht weh nicht erzählt na ja jetzt auch
noch eins ist könnte ich mir jetzt das
können jetzt darf man sich kleidet
möchten könnte dann will ich auch später
annehmen und dann kommen wir vielleicht
auch mal ins match ein
das flugzeug liegt auf jeden fall nicht
mehr in echt aber ist ja egal
zurückfliegen
absolut sowie flugzeuge nicht
funktionieren oder hier kann man
schießen leute ich hab das gefühl ist
ein bisschen betrunken habe ich mich
natürlich schon seit dem flugzeug hat
weil die ich bin natürlich ein cooles
nein
also ich weiß ja nicht ob flugzeuge sich
so verhalten würden ängste noch mal
nicht ist hier ein
man kann aber halt mit dem flugzeug
ähnlich wie bei der tram und das war es
mit dem match man kann aber bei den er
mit dem flugzeug ähnlich wie bei der
kursraum auf
das machen dann geht es ab genau ich bin
jetzt mal eine millisekunde welt
gekommen nur ganz kurz jemandem hallo
sagen aber ich glaube das war jetzt auch
des spielmodus und jetzt gehts jetzt
baut sich einmal als ab und an bord als
auf ich bin vieles gleich
[Musik]
so halte an der stelle ich bin einfach
mal wieder da vielen dank das ja dann
die leben seit an alle würde ich jetzt
gerade neuen intel neue in den sinn
gekommen sind und einfach schon gesehen
haben wie ich die ganze zeit offen heute
nicht geben
nein ich hätte mich haben wir schon
hätten dem es ist egal absolut geil so
laut cook ich glaube ich alles klar
der kreative modus ist offenbar ziemlich
doof bisschen chaotisch aber wenn man
damals mit freunden spielt die man schon
kennt oder so dann ist es absolut genial
ich glaube auch dass wir jetzt nur noch
videos im kreativ modus bringen wird
weil man da halt einfach so viele
möglichkeiten hat die man einfach davor
noch nicht hatte hat jetzt weg den
hätten jahrelang mit einem remis
ja er hat sich
ich gehe die sache ein bisschen fliegen
gekommen
das ist absolut unter den augen flugzeug
naja den trichter nicht der hat selbst
einige haarige der war close-ups dann
trifft er mit so einer panzerfaust nie
das überlebt der hat gesessen
scheinbar so gut ist und herr mangold
die anschließend von jetzt an alles
nackt war
[Musik]
und damit hätte er textete und
der leute habe ich gesagt dass es hier
fair zugeht darf man sich glaube ich
nicht
da habe ich gesagt das ist hier fair
zugeht habe ich überhaupt nicht nein du
hast du schaust du mit mir treffen habe
der schlecht sind derweil gut kommen wir
nächstes jahr wird sich die einfach alle
weg zur bombe mit meinem sie alle gegen
mich ist oder was war habe ich den in
der luft getroffen haben es ist der wert
auch nicht ankommt immer geht es mir ja
hallo sage ich dir nicht hören kann
nein ich kann gar nicht liegen ich kann
ihn nicht töten wollen
kommt nämlich mal ein kleines match das
ich fliege
ja gut space bae schreibt gerade wenig
kreativ modus ist sowas von minecraft
abgeschaut
ja gut dann mache ich auch dran
ja absolut geplant noch mal viele gegner
auf jeden fall also landet man alle
immer auf diesem großen berg da mal ein
bisschen mehr action würde ich sagen
dass wir uns ein bisschen streckt sich
ein bisschen zu sehr für mich persönlich
dass ich da nicht hinten kann ich kann
ich nicht hätten sowohl also
ich fliege jetzt mache ich ja nicht
absichtlich
auch wenn es mal du hast du bist nicht
mein team das willst du ja
die leute groß sind die leute jetzt
darum in seiner jetzt irgendwie direkt
dazu georg e
nein also ob ich mich gekillt habe ihn
nicht macht ja schön dass sie angenehm
dafür gehe ich muss manchmal mit dem
fest können bisher 107 mich nämlich auch
immer mit einem gesicht wenn ich immer
so herunter hängen absolut geil jetzt
gerade auch noch mal die gelegenheit auf
jeden fall wird genutzt um werbung für
meint rich kann halt zu machen könnt ihr
direkt mal reingehen auch gerne in der
beschreibung werden in zukunft gegen dem
einziges kind kann natürlich auch worten
halt ab und so auch sogar minecraft ja
falls irgendwer von immer mal gespielt
falls das noch irgendwann wir ja ich
habe das immer übel gailland auch weiter
bei mir
da bin ich verneige mich jetzt nicht
landen kommen aber es kann zwar gute
pflege ich jetzt mal ne danke an die
über 700 zuschauer gerade
wohin kommt den hatte ich jetzt ja jetzt
schon ein bisschen für das fliegen noch
mal das ganze nochmal mit muss halt
abend leider muss ich nicht arbeitgeber
heute abend leider auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt also ich sehe da nicht
den kanal gewechselt
danke fürs menschen gestellt sein dass
natürliche geburt kann etwas gewesen
es geht und keiner ich sehe keine wo es
seid ihr alle leute da sehr gut vorne
guten tag und tschüss wieder jetzt noch
einmal gucken muss ja so sagen hat
außerdem hielten kann man locker fest
genannt wie lange es stimmt ja ich denke
ich dass du noch so 40 minuten
solange das triumphierende eine 700
zuschauer gerade über heftig einer
echtheit ja wahrscheinlich kommen gerade
von der schule
kannst du machen den flug vielen dank
dafür
kannst du mal
kannst du mal flugzeug fliegen fragt
jemand
aber davor gönne ich mir noch ein paar
kilos hier unten wurde die kids können
sich mich lese ich weiß ja nicht
ich glaube ich habe ein bisschen punk
connection schaden den lama typen da den
kann ich nicht
da hab ich nichts gemacht gut ich gebe
dir mal zum flug geht ihr damals im
flugzeug
so was geht dir mal zum flugzeug wo ist
da ein flugzeug in dem flugzeug ich
glaube ich kann er für neues bauen wenn
ich wollte ich kann nur staunen wenn ich
nicht in der in stade
das flugzeug jetzt wo ich mein haus
kommt mir vor
kann man speichern im cut egal ich
konnte gerade speicherverfahren schon
kreativ modus dann ist das ganze ding
abgestürzte aber neu gestartet ist und
da war die map gottseidank einmal auch
mal da ist ein kollege das der grund
warum glaubst ist mir schon immer ein
dorn im auge gewesen gar nicht dass das
der ist denn die ganze gilt
da kann ich jetzt auch in ruhe im
flugzeug snacken so flugzeuge jetzt auch
ins flugzeug und alle leute wenn sie
jetzt fragen hey du kannst ja niemals
starten ich meinen macht gar keinen sinn
daher zu starten da ist ja über gebäude
erzeugt aber man kann mit dem flugzeug
dass ich einfach ich werde fliegen wir
mit jedem guten flugzeug also insofern
kein problem
ich hätte das mal ein arzt überhaupt
geschossen hat ist krass die können auf
jeden fall da nichts
also erstmal das passiert hier oben ganz
klar so wie man es im flugzeug einfach
machen kann in echt auch so es ist so
ich legte dann auch nochmal direkt dazu
dem berg u
ich kann aber die hersteller natürlich
kann ich nicht jeden tag kann ich du
bist es gewesen so ich bin ja kein
flugzeug ich bin mensch alle
nein ich will nicht sterben hilfe ja wow
so viel ich kann jetzt noch nicht lenken
logischerweise ja sogar das war es dann
ich weiß noch nicht wie lange ich kann
ja immer landen kann er dann hoch
fliegen wie der größten hacker der hier
auch bin so
tschüss und wieder zu fliegen können
oder ich schreibe meine zeit ist es
unfair da sie fliegen kann oder nicht
ich weiß ja nicht ich weiß es nicht
ja
ich glaube dem irak ich meinte er wobei
wenn man wenn man pflegt hat man sogar
kein eng mit den dingen der macht sich
bruder was soll das was soll das was
soll das so kann man soll das denn so
und ist eine maxime überraschen kann
oder nicht glaubt ihr lässt sich nicht
so gerne überraschen wer weiß schon was
ich da aber der hertha ist da und der
zweite auf ja ganz nett sie fliegen zu
können muss man einfach sagen
damit der impuls nicht hier denkt er
kann er auf liegen dicke kommt diese
leute
traurig all das aber nicht getroffen hat
als ob ich denn irgendwie das halt das
beste ist wenn die leute mich einfach
fertig machen
obwohl ja wohin fliegen können das ist
ganz traurig dass joshua schönen tag
noch muss eigentlich wo landen können
ich stehe noch eine halbe stunde an all
die fragen ich muss das eigentlich nur
noch landen können
und ja dann wäre ich absolut geil dann
kann ich mit ihr fliegen und mit
suchmaschinen kommt den gegenwärtigen
heller aber gut wie du willst du machen
kannst
mag schon mal halt ich weiß 60 bis 120
euro liegen und fliege
ja klar vom fliegen auch nicht ich
glaube aber dass ich dafür eine bessere
pumpgun braucht eine shotgun meine ich
und vielleicht noch die hier nein aus
westen zeigt ausrüsten
doch jetzt auf die entfernung der stadt
galt also fast schon vorher übertreibt
ein held und ich bin tot oder was weiß
dass musiker sein
knappe sache kannst du bitte einen
anderen modus spielen ja ist meine
gründe normal spielen und dann ja genau
ich werde jetzt gleich noch mal eine
runde nicht kreativ spielen sondern
einfach nur mal so loose oder so weil du
einmal bis felix magath flieger ich mag
ich bin noch nicht weil ich biete also
entsteht ja auch nicht aber jetzt halt
meint server und deswegen kann ich
nirgendwo und jahr liegt ja nicht okay
das war jetzt absolut unfair was gerade
betrieben hat ich war doch mal jeden
hier ein
mein gefängnis ja nicht so ganz
funktioniert ich dachte ich könnte ja
sie einbauen wie so ein killer magier
des todes einfach aber schon geklappt
naja julian franken gerade würdest du
mal einen 84 stunden live stream machen
das habe ich mit 24 stunden antun wollen
das fünfmal so viel was ich schon so gar
nicht passt zu zwölf stunden safe mal
aber 24 stunden nach der hand getroffen
muss ich glaube jetzt einfach
und hätte denn
dafür spielen
bevor er schon sein
gehen wir von uns bei der kirche ich
liebe zuerst eine frage gerade was ist
das für ein spiel - das ist der kreativ
musste wo man hat einfach mehr oder
weniger schicken kann und alle waffen
hat ich zeige heute diesem menü an alle
leute die jetzt neu sind aber dann die
730 zuschauer hatten also hat er noch
nie
danke dafür und ich werde jetzt mal ganz
kurz vielleicht einen neuen leute zeigen
wie das aussieht ihr mann ich habe ja
alle waffen einfach was natürlich schon
gesagt ich könne theoretisch mir ja ich
kann mir jetzt theoretisch stehen hier
ausrüsten könnt ihr dann damit herum
fliegen und dann einfach mal ein
bisschen spam so zeigt mal gucken wie er
damit klarkommt
deshalb kommen sie damit gut klar weil
ja so ein bisschen unfair ist es ja
schon
okay ist schon krass und her
aber es macht einfach kein spaß also was
ist das ein händler
dieses handy ermöglicht mir jetzt passen
auf dass handys geisteskrank ich kann
jetzt einfach hier zum beispiel diese
uhr mit dem handy mopsen die uhr mit dem
handy klauen und ich kann jetzt einfach
aber ich muss nochmal diebe klauen
ich kann jetzt einfach überall hin bauen
und die fallen der same runter so kann
jetzt aber ihr überall uhren in zwei
oder hier nimmt die uhren
aber jetzt kann er überall uhren also
das hat heftig so eine das handy ist
megageil macht es spaß ja es macht schon
spaß also muss man einfach mal sagen ich
denke ich kann erst ich muss immer erst
landen ich könnte theoretisch fliegen
aber um fliegen zu können müsst ihr
erstmal landen
ich glaub ich mache noch mal ein
bisschen handy action nicht schon mal
ein bisschen weil die ganzen zeit ja
schon im flugzeug gebe der weg einfach
nutzen weil irgendwas was es sonst nicht
gibt wo ich könnte mir den hier neben
den hier die frage was ist so ein blog
den mann aber normal nicht bauen kann so
was hier zum beispiel das könnte man ja
nochmal jetzt nicht bauen oder dass hier
kann ich noch mal nicht bauen
jetzt kann jetzt einfach mit hoch gehen
ja und ich glaube eigentlich mehr oder
weniger so oft bauen wie ich will und
zwar genau so muss es einfach überall
hin als fällt dann auch automatisch
runter ich kann es aber auch stapeln
anfang also warum man gott ich will ja
nicht wie das aussehen wird
oh mein gott was ist das alter das jetzt
mega stadion
so kann ich die leute einsperren ja
etwas gutes das gut
von max bolze sonst nicht abschließen so
aber ganz kurz hier so ein wesen der
umgebauten große ding so heißt es aber
die leute gehen nicht gerade hier
scheint wahr
dies scheint so also kann man von oben
dann können ja jetzt gleich mal von oben
sehen wie das aussieht jetzt so jamann
wir schweben auf jeden fall ein oder
anderen blöcken luft herum und ich werde
jetzt aber haben dafür sogar vom fliegen
mit der paritäten verbalattacken
wie kann man es mit alt also ich muss
doch bodenlangen und der typ muss dafür
so gnädig sein und mich nicht zu zählen
und was nicht wird nämlich nicht tief
definitiv definitiv nein
so ist der 4 jetzt will der unter und
dann mal gucken was der so macht es ja
gut dass man jetzt
in serie ein
wo war der wo war das kurz genau gesehen
man kann den kreativ machen was man will
ist ein echt gas kann so sogar zwei
wochen ein
jetzt haben wir gesehen da oben dieses
riesen ding und da werde ich jetzt auch
mal gerne im flugzeug einfliegen leute
haben ja gefragt hey hey hey was die
jaaa den baum ein flugzeug das was man
auf sofern sich die jetzt nicht killen
ja und ich bin jetzt einfach mal die
neubi stellen so dass hier mal weg
machen dann kann ich hier eigentlich
muss man den platz bebauen
so kann ich nicht bauen kann er nicht
bauen
jetzt kann ich werde mich nicht gehen
sogar dann irgendwann die zahlen jetzt
nicht den rücken ich war einfach nur
flugzeug kriegen okay das wäre super
als dankeschön kriegstagen flugzeug habe
da kann man natürlich jetzt pass auf
ganz einfach möglich weiß wie man
flugzeuge machen kann durch gebäude
fliegen ja halb oder was geht ja schon
auf genau so wir sehen fast frei alter
was geht also die physik haben sie auf
einem richtig herausgefordert
das ist nicht wahr ich werde einfach
noch nach oben fliegen junge was ist los
ich habe viele leute passen denn da hin
kommt wo bei dir
jetzt bekommt kein garnichts schaden
machen ist dass wir die alten bruder so
flugzeug jetzt können wir gern mit
aufsteigen genau so jetzt fliegen wir
leute danke an die 860 zuschauer gerade
heftig heftig so ich fliege jetzt aber
mal so bisschen rum und hoffe einfach
dass mich die leute nicht abgehalten
ihr seht schon was wir gerade hier
fabriziert haben im kreativ modus ja da
kann man auf jeden fall sein oder ja
anstellen will ich mal geholfen junge
also auf ein flugzeug das heißt es los
mit dem neubau des zwillings konflikte
rein nein was was passiert jetzt
ich wollte einfliegen
ich wollte doch fliegen sollte jetzt mal
im flugzeug zu starten ohne dass mich
einer geld ist natürlich absolut geil
hier zu wenig platz braucht nur ein
flugzeug zu bauen
auffüllen und dann jetzt direkt
durchstarten nahe haben mich kurz ist
aber ihr seht kann sich das flugzeug
läuft dann die 900 zuschauer gerade
heftig stay
das ist ganz krank danke auf jeden fall
dafür
wir versuchen jetzt nochmal das flugzeug
zu fliegen ohne dass mich einer von
diesen leuten aktive ja das wäre echt
schon nett aber ich glaube gedenken
wollen es nicht so ganz
sie muss ich davon abhalten mich zu
geben indem ich ihnen zuvorkommen leicht
was aber auch gar nicht so schwer sein
fall ist sollte weil ich kann ja auch
fliegen so gysi
ich schaue mir jetzt bitte
ein flugzeug so drin ist die normale web
wie seht ihr vielleicht gibt es auch
dieses schöne schnee weil ich ja mal
gucken habe ich den vielleicht ein
bisschen schaden machen kann liga
bekommen
dieses flugzeug so viel aber es ist
nicht unrealistisch
ich habe vorhin schon zwei drei klicks
mit dem flugzeug gemacht aber jetzt
gerade will es nicht so ganz
die steuerung leicht ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig jetzt lag zeit übel
des todes und einer mit denen auch
catchen kann jetzt gleich muss ja immer
ein bisschen weit ausholen um überhaupt
jemanden treffen zu können so
ansonsten lerne ein bisschen ist
flugzeug schon ziemlich spät erst einmal
gerettet und jetzt zweimal gilt das war
es aber auch erstmal okay dann habe ich
jetzt im luft gebrannt eigentlich werde
auch ton also eigentlich werden schon
geht als ob dir und auf mein flugzeug
springt und mich dann gilt was der
glaube er hat jetzt ein flugzeug gesehen
und dann die das schreiben kommt ist
schule ja ich will vorbei ist und ich
jetzt einfach ein bisschen rum pflegen
wenn die leute mit meiner abfackeln
während ich fliege was ihm unfair ist
aber naja so ist ja gut das war's mit
dem kieler auf jeden fall oder hier in
die pampa hier sind noch irgendwo
begegnet ich weiß es doch der wohl auch
gekillt und nicht von mir also muss ich
irgendwie gegner sein
ja das waren
ein geiler modus ist effektives und die
schliche wir sind zu weltruhm oder
muster so richtig geil da oben ist die
nächste luanda das man dir vorhin auf
jeden fall
nein ich am fallschirm war es war schön
da bin ich mir als opfer genauso stark
wenn ich fliegen kann leider so jesu
irgendwo dann tut
ich glaube ich mache es nochmals im ziel
dieses flugzeug zu wählen oder erstmal
den com
er ist ob ich nicht getroffen habe
gut
dass ich nicht getroffen
tja was machst du jetzt
das ist richtig und werde mich aber ich
kann immer noch sterben also so krass
ist jetzt auch nicht
wie kann ich beitreten
du musst wenn du von der freundesliste
willst dann kannst du offen wie sie
beitreten
ansonsten wäre ich habe vor ein ganz
viele von euch hier geändert aber ja ja
die zeiten vorbei junge erhält er war
auch nicht gut gespielt von mir leider
wie kann man den kreativ modus reihen
man braucht aktuell noch für den
kreativen muss den bettel parat haben 13
also müsste österreich dann aber nicht
um die kaufmann 13 gibt es auch ohne
brettl pass genau wenn du bist nicht
warten wollte dann braucht die leider
den bettel passt ja bruder
aber nicht gereift ist
tschüss
sie haben ein gutes make up at liga was
ist denn los mit dem
nein kazuya comic spielt ein
leute ich gehe mal raus tut mir leid ist
aber geht es noch glaube ich auch
offline mensch verlassen die haben mich
verlassen und es war ein spiel als mal
ganz normales ohne unentschieden einfach
mal ein bisschen ruhig ich glaube dass
dann auch ganz geil ich weiß ja noch ein
solo core solo einfach mal die neue map
ab 7 jahre weil die schneepiste heftig
so lukrativen gruppe verlassen ja solo
jetzt annehmen soll oder ein techno die
neue map was die so zu bieten hat ja ich
habe diesmal wird noch gar nicht gesehen
ich war die ganze zeit kreativ modus
jetzt ist egal was sie wieder mitgemacht
habe ich hab gesehen die map ist gerade
absolut weiß überall und ultra
verschneit also richtig heftig genau
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt was ich da
jetzt heißen kann ja also ich weiß nicht
ob ich jetzt im solo so viel gebacken
kriegt man ja die 850 auch zeigt nochmal
den bettel passt bitte weil er den
bettel paar szenen dann würde jetzt noch
mal kurz genießen und den bettel pass
zeigen nicht verlassen ich zeige euch
nochmal eine battle preis kommt was es
neues gibt und danach gehen aber die
neue map abchecken was da so abgeht
spiel doch mal thomas sagt es ist eine
gute idee eigentlich in dem kaff modus
so könnte man es auch echt machen also
da können zwar keine 101 103 und so
gehen die anderen aber ja trotzdem heißt
also erstmal der itemshop ja was sagt
der itemshop der sagt es gibt absolut
nichts neues leider also gut wir schon
gehen trotzdem gekauft weil ich geil
finde aber ansonsten hier im shop gibt
auch nichts neues jahr
alles was hier neues er gibt es ein paar
events sie halt noch so an stehen ganz
klar die herausforderung die sind ja
hier logisch aber hier der battle passt
was ist hier so gibt da gibt es einmal
zu dieses spray das eigentlich schon
ganz witzig ist stufe erwerben ja ich
komme nächstes stand exchange ein
exakter ich könnte mir einfach mal ein
bisschen durch jetzt bei den kosten 150
ja gut krieg komme ich irgendwohin also
ich hab ich werde jetzt keine neuen
wibag können aber ich habe noch keine
kondensstreifen die kann ich mir glaub
ich gönne ich glaube ich von mir mal die
kondensstreifen ja dann haben wir diesen
wallpapers gaildorf sonne richtig schöne
werk schon heute steht und honda wie
bugs noch zusätzlich also 400 wachsen
sich zu fast ein battle points zu kaufen
weil eine stufe zu kaufen ja ja so die
nächste stufe können nicht mehr aus
dann habe ich jetzt den hier endlich das
mein erster kondensstreifen wurde aber
auch mal zeit da ist da ist ein box
enthält der open was gibt es in der
nächsten zeit als herz ich würde
vielleicht noch was ich total gerne
hätte wär ja an und für sich so diese
gesagt desktop oder die streifen weil
das eine richtigkeit ist ob das dann
über die ganze abgespielt
und das geht ja noch ganz cool aber an
und für sich wenn ich mir jetzt
vielleicht das nachholen
ja komm perfekt neuerdings bisschen was
weihnachtliches am start dann kann ich
mir jetzt gut in den spind oha als taste
808 diesen skin für eine waffe als ob
das als ob die praxis mit allen farben
so machten holy shit das ja geil als ob
junge lebt man ja alles wobei den hätte
dann hätte ich gern den ihr der musik
glaube ich ja nix na ja so ganz klar ja
ich habe ich jetzt über die lackierung
drin und dann machen wir noch ein
rucksack reichen wir gleich diesen
weihnachtlichen rucksack rein
es geht mir eigentlich happy und dann
hier habe ich den hier jetzt und als das
solle man jetzt mal ein solo und jannis
sagt ich könnte dir thomas sagt mal
organisieren ich würde dir dann ein
diskutabler man eine coole idee aber in
dem kritik muss kann man ja nur zu 16 2
1 oder jahren ist also gut ist wird auch
trotzdem reichen führen so lobo also für
wie gesagt und erst mal sorry leute die
gerade der gruppe trennten
ich muss erstmal raus weil ich kann so
spielen will gerne annehmen spiel so
dann checken jetzt mal ab was da so
abgeht
wir können erkennen jetzt mal die
kommentare schreiben wie sieht es denn
aus mit verbindungen legt das gerade
oder halt auch nicht genau
gut also ist da hätte konnte ist gerade
gar nicht mehr jetzt das mal kurz mal
gespannt ob das schön haben jetzt
wirklich alle waffen dich einsammeln
diesem dieses gilt ja als ob es jetzt
bei waffen skins gibt gas
so gesehen dass andere auch
wahrscheinlich oder coole sagen wir eine
pistole ist jetzt einfach so gemustert
galler 16 leute bestimmt auch lucia das
recht das machen wir mal ein bisschen
einspielen so landen wir natürlich als
ob die sogar zählte towers so verschneit
haben da war natürlich klar oder
ich glaube geht mal rüber und ich sind
wahrscheinlich alle menschen auch
einfach hier auf dieser tour und da guck
doch mal wie wir bekommen ja genau
noch mal ganz kurz an alle ja wenn ihr
noch mal wenn ihr mehr street um ihr
sehen wollt dann könnt euch gerne hier
bei switch rein entweder rettet das
natürlich in einem browser ein oder
sogar bei den etv seid dann könnt euch
auch einfach
doch einfach den link in der video
beschreibung dann müsst ihr nämlich
nicht dass meine lieben software ich
glaube ich gut find das natürlich als ob
man auch eis kriegt holy shit aber nicht
ganz so lang wie bei dem eis altena okay
hier war schon mal eine waffe trennen
die bringen als im markt hat
wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel aber die
hat sich die auch schon gesagt na ja gut
ist doch egal ist ihm auch egal
ich könnte jetzt einfach mal sterbe
gutermann der stelle jetzt kommt noch
eine runde zurück zum spiel gucken was
so geht okay wir können da noch mal ins
darüber quatschen wann dir das machen
wir das einfach sagen ja wir sind direkt
hier eine kuppel gruppe verlassen nicht
will dass ganz kurzen solo aus kicken so
dass wir jetzt auch die letzte woche
seien leute ich werde danach erst mal
was essen gehen vielen dank an die
ganzen zuschauer heute aber danach werde
hier das mal reinhauen und bisschen
lecker essen und danach wieder im revier
videos schneiden kommen die heute 18 uhr
wasser ja und ich teste auch mal ein
bisschen die map sowie die aussieht also
schön verschneit ist finde ich echt
ultra das epic games immer wieder
kredenzt hat für und zur weihnachtszeit
will dann gibt es wenigstens in
weihnachten weise ergibt wenig sinn
fordert weiße weihnacht wenn schon nicht
in echt dann wahrscheinlich
genau dann geht es wenigstens wie gesagt
in freuen wenn es schon echt keine gibt
wobei man das nicht weiß ob die pumpgun
zitiert
die pumpgun ist gerade ein paar komplett
die musste heftig denn ist einfach ein
geschenk papier und um gewickelt ok
sowie landen ja ich glaube schiff
geschäftsmann chefs geschäft zieht über
darüber sobald diese wickele gegen da
ist auch cool truck ich glaube ich lag
da noch mal auch wenn es gerade nicht so
geklappt hat
ja er kann zudem mikrofon bisschen laut
zu stellen ist ein bisschen schwierig
kann ein bisschen näher herangehen
aber leider kann ich es nicht machen
sorry und hausbau was ich auch urteil
gefunden hätte wären bei den preisen
park winter gewesen wäre gewesen park
ist allzu gefühlt die geilste stadt
meiner meinung nach hätte es gibt sogar
schlitz barca und die kerne tine
schreibt gerade in köln bleibt liegen
und das stimmt tatsächlich auch wobei es
letztes jahr natürlich sogar schon
schnee gab es war das erste der es im
monat den ich in köln war und alle so
yeah in köln gibt es keinen schnee
und dann war der erste monat da und da
gab es rufe schnee wieder gut die lange
habe ich über verkackt mal schauen haben
irgendwie ein bisschen ludwig über
bleibt heute da drüben ist
unwahrscheinlich vorliegt werde ich halt
noch im umgang mit der waffe
da drin ist eine pistole gesehen aber
die nehmen
immerhin weniger so tempo netz abgreifen
hier natürlich ganz schön ruhig
die ist auch cool finde ich wollte man
natürlich auch erst sinn wenn man ja
einen gewissen punkt ist halt im game
nur weil jetzt eine schöne pampa
natürlich besser auch hier seine kiste
die ist auch gut so grau aber besser ist
nicht so den könnt ich mir geld mal ein
neuer modus möglichkeit schon gespielt
ich spiele jetzt gerade die neue web
einfach um einfach mal zu checken was
ihnen ab so zu bieten hat und was die
neuen app zu die veränderten ab jetzt zu
bieten hat der fca viel schnee zu bieten
und die waffe habe ich ja kursziel 9
das war so nett kürzlich wurden immer
wieder schwach also sorry für den lost
ja na ja auf jeden fall
danke für die garten zuschauer cool das
ist alles dabei was ich werde jetzt
etwas leckeres essen habe noch schönen
abend dann schon nachmittag und können
aber jetzt mal spielen viel spaß damit
und habe ich sagen haut rein für sie
robert a
was gut voran